hey folks in this video I'm going to
show you a new quick way to build a
react and spring boot application
we're going to build a full stack to do
application using a spring boot Java
backend a reactant typescript front end
connected by the hello framework by
button so let's jump right into code and
see how we can do this
all right so here I'm in my terminal I'm
going to use npx to run the Hella CLI
I'm going to run init pass in the react
parameter and we're going to call our
project to do
so once this finishes what we're going
to do is we're going to go into that
folder
so CD to do and then we're going to open
it up in an ID I'm going to use
uh intelli jide but you can use any any
ID that you prefer
so once this opens up we can go ahead
and take a look at what we have
um
all right so let's load the maven
project and while that is going on let's
go into the actual project and look at
the pom file
all right so if we look at the file we
can see that we have a spring boot
project and we have some additional
stuff here like the hello framework
since we are building a full stack
application I'm going to add a database
here we're just going to use an
in-memory H2 database for this and then
I'm going to add the spring boot data
jpa
dependency so that we get spring data
and jpa
so Springwood starter
jpa let's see if we can find there yep
there we go we can remove the version
information like that
okay so if we go back into the project
here you can see that we have two
interesting Parts here we have the
source folder which includes our spring
boot application and then we have a
front-end folder here which is our react
application the way we start both of
these is by running the application the
spring boot application from here you
could also run it through Maven if you
prefer that way
what you see Happening Here is that
running the spring boot application not
only starts spring boot but it actually
starts a front-end build tool here beat
and that's going to compile our
front-end assets and uh kind of live
reload stuff as we as we code
so the first time we run this it'll take
a little while and once it's done we'll
have this kind of simple to view
application up here and that's something
that was generated by that starter
now we are not going to use any of those
views so I'm going to simplify the
application a little bit but before we
do that let me just create some more
space for us here
all right so
in our react application you can see
that we have an index file we have a
index Ts that initializes the react
application and then we have a routes
file uh so he'll already set up a react
router for us
we're not going to use any of these
views that it generated so we can just
go ahead and delete those and create one
new for ourselves and this is going to
be called to do
view.tsx because we are using typescript
here and we're going to export a
function
called to do View
and to do view will return
some jsx and in here we will wrap
everything in a div and we can create an
H1 just say
hello cool
to do like that
all right so we can still see the the
build is failing because we have all
these routes that are uh trying to load
stuff that we don't have anymore so
let's map the empty path here to our new
to do view component so we'll do element
it's equal to to do
do a view like that and then we can
delete much of what was here from before
now of course if you're building a more
meaningful application you probably want
to keep a lot of what's there okay and
the reason this is failing because we're
going to the about view which we don't
have
and if we go to the root here we can see
we have our hello call to do
all right so the way I want to tackle
building application is start let's
start on the back end we're going to
create a data model an entity for our to
do we're going to create a repository so
we can access them from the database and
then we're going to create an endpoint
which is something that hilly uses to
connect the client with the server so
it's essentially like a rest endpoint
but with type safety
so let's jump into the application
package here create a new Java class to
do
and to do will be an entity
so we'll annotate this with a entity so
jpa entity
entity like that uh what's going on ADD
spring boot start I thought we already
did but sure go ahead
all right so we do that then we need to
add a ID otherwise it's going to be
angry so we'll do a private long ID then
we'll have a private
string for the task and then we'll have
a private Boolean for the done state
like that for the ID we're gonna
annotate that with a ID annotation and
we're going to add a
generated value like that so
we can let
jpa take care of generating the values
I'm going to create two Constructors
here for us uh first one will be
one taking in a task just for
convenience and then jpa requires us to
have a Constructor that takes in no
parameters so just a nor Arc Constructor
and then finally I'm going to generate
all the Getters and Setters that we need
all right so that takes care of our data
model pretty simple
stuff
the next thing we need is a way to
actually save and get these from the
database so for that we're going to
create a new interface called to do
Repository
and this is going to use spring data and
we're just going to extend from the jpa
repository let's hide the sidebar here
uh pass in the type of the entity that
we have and the type of the ID key that
it has
and with that we are now ready to create
our endpoint so the that's going to be
the code that we used actually or the
API that we use to connect to the server
from the client
going to go into the endpoints package
here delete the stuff that was generated
by the starter and I'm going to create a
new class here called to do endpoint
endpoints are like I said similar to
rest controllers that they are an API
that we can use to call the server the
difference is that they are type safe
the way we Define one is by adding an
endpoint annotation to our class and
then I'm also going to add Anonymous
allowed meaning that anyone is allowed
to call this normally only logged in
users would be able to call this
then let's Auto wire in
this repository that we have so we have
the to do a repository I'll call this
repository and then we will
create a field for it
and once we have that we can actually
start creating our API so what I need
from the server is one method for
fetching all the to Do's one for adding
a new to do based on a task name that I
have and then one method for updating a
to do
so let's just start going through these
one at a time we're going to create a
public method that returns a list
of these to do items and we can call
this find all
and what final will do is it will just
return
what we get from the repository find all
like that
good all right so next one will be a
method that returns it to do
and it will be called add it takes in a
string
for the task that we want to do and
Returns what we get back from calling
repository dot save
with a new
to do with that task
all right so just be sure to kind of
return this newly created to do so that
we can display it in the client and then
finally we'll have a another method
returning a to do which will be update
this actually takes in a to do
and Returns what we get from calling
repository.save with that to do
right good stuff so now we have a
endpoint with all these methods that we
want to call from the client I'm going
to build a project
which will make those available to us in
typescript
so let's see if that works Uh
something's not happy maybe it's still
running
all right so there we have it
all right so we will go back to our
to-do view here and what I want to do
now is call the back end to get all the
to-do's that we might have there from
the before
and then we need to store them somewhere
and for that we're going to create a
state we're going to create a constant
state that is for the to do's and we
will also have a set to do Setter for
that state
and we're going to use the react use
State hook for this I'm not going to go
through how State and hooks work in
react so I'll leave a link in the show
notes if you're not familiar with that
just understand that we get a state that
we can reference and a Setter for
setting that state here because we're
using typescript I'm going to define the
type here to be a to do array
and you can see that we actually were
able to import this from this generated
folder and we can see that the type here
matches our
uh Java object and we didn't have to do
that so anytime we make a change to that
Java model this to do type will get
updated in our front-end folder as well
so we have full stack type safety and
we'll have full stack autocomplete which
is really really nice
okay so with that we now need a way to
actually call the server for that we're
going to use another hook the use effect
took which allows us to do run things
that have a side effect like calling the
server in in this case takes in two
things a function which is the actual
function to run and then a array of
dependencies so anytime anything in this
array changes we want to rerun this in
our case we don't want to rerun it we
just want to run it once so we leave the
dependency array empty and in here we
will call our to do endpoint
to find all
and then when they get back to us we
will call set to do's
all right so let's take a look at what
we just did we called the server through
this method
instead of doing a rest call to a URL
we're calling a typescript method under
the hood Hiller we'll create a rest
endpoint to call uh for this but we
don't have to care about where that URL
is or anything we can call this in a
type safe manner now the other thing to
note here is that we have a red squiggly
line here on our to-do's and that's
because Java and typescript handle type
safety a little bit different so in Java
pretty much anything can be null and a
typescript nothing can be null unless we
specify it that it can be now I'm going
to go into my endpoints folder here
and create a package info
and say that this should be a nun null
API so essentially what I'm telling
hello here is that I'm not going to
return any null values from my backend
code and by doing that we can really
simplify the typescript generation here
because we don't need to check
everything for null ability
all right so we can see that the app
built here and the squiggly lines went
away
now of course we don't have any to Do's
here that we could show because we don't
have a way of adding to Do's yet so
let's do that next for that I'm going to
create a new uh State here for the task
and we're going to bind that to a text
field
so again let's create a new constant
here for the task and a Setter for that
so set task
that'll be equal to U state with an
empty string to start out
so now that we have the state that we
need we now need kind of a small form
for this so I'm going to create a small
div
and this div will then have a
text field
and it will have a button
like I said hello comes with components
built in so we don't have to actually go
and search for third-party components
that we can use
give this a label add and let's use a
theme on this so we want to use the
primary variant
of this button like that I'm also going
to use
some utility classes that we ship here
so I'm going to
use class name here
and then I'm going to say that this
should be a
flexbox and it should have a
small gap between the components here
likewise I don't like that the entire
view touches the browser here so I'm
gonna give a class name here with
padding medium like that just to give us
a little bit of breathing room here
all right so we have the state here we
have a text field that we want to bind
it to so we'll start by binding the
value
to the task here so whatever the
State here is so if we change the state
that should always reflect in the type
in the text field
and likewise we're going to add a on
change event listener here so whenever
it changes we want to update the state
so for that we're going to add a event
listener and call set state
uh so sorry set task and we're going to
get the target value so the target is
the text field and the value is the
value of the text field like that
okay so now that we have
the actual task in our in our state here
we want to add a I want to click
listener to our button and we're going
to call a add to do function
we're going to use the ID to create the
function and in here what we want to do
is we want to call the server call this
endpoint that we created uh where's that
endpoint we want to call this add with a
string
so we're going to go in here and we're
going to turn this into a
async function
and here we are going to call to do
endpoint dot add and then we are going
to pass in that task
now if you if you recall here in our
endpoint we return the to do
so we want to capture that on the client
here so we'll have a constant
called saved which will be equal to what
we get back from here
and this and every other call to the
server is going to be an async call so
we will await the value there and if
things go well if we have a saved object
we can do something with it what we want
to do with it is append it to our state
append it to our list of to-do's the way
we do that is by calling set to-do's
creating a new array with all the
previous to-do's and then appending this
newly saved object to that and then once
we're done with that we can clear the
task by just giving an empty string to
that
okay so now we have a way of adding to
do's let's try it out
by
milk
and by clicking add we can see that it
disappeared from here so something may
or may not have happened certainly we
got to here but we don't yet have a way
of displaying all these to do so let's
go ahead and do that so below our form
here we're going to go ahead and map
over all the to do so we're going to
take the to Do's map over them
and then for each to do we're going to
return some jsx I'm going to create a
div for
uh for each to do and we're going to
have a
check box there which will be the to do
done state so we'll say that the checked
value should be equal to the to-do's
done value and again here we're using
typescript so we can actually use
autocomplete to see see the properties
that we have
and then we'll have a span which will be
let's reduce
task and because we're mapping here uh
react wants us to define a key which is
something unique for each to do and for
that we can use the to do so ID
like this
all right so let's save let's see if
that shows up sure by milk bye
eggs
all right so that works now what we want
to do is hook up this checkbox so that
we actually are able to save those
changes back to the client so or to the
server I should say so right now if we
check these refresh we reset the state
because we never persisted it anywhere
so for that we are going to add a new
listener here so on
on check changed we get an event and
what we want to do is call a update to
do we're going to pass in the to do and
then
the value from this event which will be
in the detail object and the value is a
Boolean because this checkbox
now of course we don't have this
function yet so we're going to use the
ID to create it again
and the to-do will be of type to do the
value we want to call done
and then for the actual
uh server call here we're going to again
use an async
function
and we're going to call that endpoint
but this time with that
update method here so we're going to
pass in a to-do object and we get back
and updated to do object
so again we'll use the same same pattern
as above here so we're going to do a
const saved is equal to a weight and
then we're going to call the to do
endpoint
and we're gonna update
and we want to pass in a updated to do
object so for that I'm going to create a
new object
and here I'm going to destructure the
to-do that we've passed in and then I'm
going to pass in the done State here so
that overrides whatever it the previous
value was
then if we have a
saved object returned to us we can go
ahead and update our to do state so
we're going to again call set to do's
and this time what we're going to do is
we're going to map over the array that
we have and we're going to look at each
existing item and see if it matches if
the ID matches to the saved one if so
we're going to swap that out and leave
all the other ones uh B
so we're going to take the to-do's
and we're going to map over them
let's call this exists thing
just so we can keep track of things and
then we can see that if the existing ID
is equal to the saved ID
then we'll swap that out if not we're
gonna just return the existing object
and not touch it
like that
all right save again
and if things worked we should be able
to check check off some of these
refresh and see that we actually still
get that state so we're actually
persisting these to our database now
all right so there you have it in just a
few minutes we built a full stack to do
application using a spring boot Java
back end a react typescript front end
using the new Halo framework from button
I hope this was helpful for you if you
have any questions ask them in the
comments below if you have ideas for new
videos let me know as well thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one bye